[Music]
I live alone and my home is chronically
cluttered and I'm just afraid that it's
a symbol of maybe a bigger issue that
I'm not seeing tell me about your home
growing up it was perfectly picked up
but if you opened a drawer or a closet
you could see everything crammed in
there but it was all a facade yes
[Music]
sir what up what up this is John with
the Dr John deloney show the greatest
mental health and emotional health and
marriage podcast ever recorded and by
ever recorded I'm pretending I am a news
channel where I just make stuff up and I
hope you believe it and then I'll try to
sell you stuff later on this show we
talk to real people who are going
through real problems and this is true I
actually do do that and and I did say
Doo and I've been walking alongs side
hurting people for two decades and
that's what we do here um I'm tired of
the non ense I'm tired of all the drama
I'm tired of the 14 steps to a better
dude there are hurting people in homes
and schools and counseling offices and
doctor's offices across the world and
I'm sick of it and so this show is about
sitting right in the middle of it
walking Straight Into the Fire and
saying hey I'll sit with you let's
figure out what we can do next let's cut
through all the nonsense let's cut
through all of it I got two phds I've
been doing this a long long time and
we're going to figure it out and I got
Kelly by far your greatest asset just
kind of like putting a governor on the
engine she makes sure we just keep
plotting along don't go Too Fast Too
Furious is that
fair it is in a sense yeah you make sure
we stay on the air I make sure you don't
take us off the air here we go all right
so it's almost Christmas time nothing
and I mean nothing says I love you and
I'm glad I'm related to you like buying
your significant other something I mean
a book about their anxiety and their
mental health so go to john.com and pick
up my number one best selling Wall
Street Journal bestselling book building
a non- anxious life go pick it up and
questions for humans we don't know how
to talk to each other anymore and I got
you questions for all different
scenarios taking away all the excuses
put your screens down stop handing your
kids digital babysitters and let's
reconnect as people so we got the
Christmas deck let's do this all right
we got two questions today so yesterday
we talked about what movie was overrated
so it's only fair that today we're going
to talk about what's the all-time
greatest Christmas
movie oh Nightmare Before Christmas no
question about
it dude Tim Burton it's a great movie
like some Playdoh incredible alltime
greatest ever Christmas
movie okay fun fact never said this on
the show before you ready for this my
dad one of his childhood best
friends was Randy
Quaid they hung out and if you can see
where I come from you can be like oh
yeah we see that way to go we see the
connection there so they were close
close buddies and so I also have to
say Christmas vacation that's what I was
going to say Christmas Vacation yeah
Cousin Eddie has got a warm place in my
heart yeah I might I mean there's part
of me that wants to say elf just cuz
it's so family friendly and I mean
everybody loves elfl um you know
Christmas vacation we didn't let our
kids watch till they were a little older
um but it's just so great I did I did
let
um my kids watched elf I think last year
and they didn't they didn't think it was
that funny what oh my kids love Elf that
we that's one we watch it every
Thanksgiving
night that's like the start to the
season just to get past gratitude and
get right to the give me gimme gimme
yeah yeah I can see that in your house
but every night my in my in-laws every
Thanksgiving night we watch Elf you know
it's kind of everybody's eaten and all
the stuff's done everybody sits down and
watches elf it's that is it's just such
a great feel-good movie how can you not
love it but Christmas Vacation still
Takes the Cake for me is that I haven't
seen it in 20 years is that kid
appropriate Christmas Vacation yeah um
not it's uh Hank appropriate not
Josephine Josephine appropriate there's
a there's some language in it mainly and
a couple of like when he's flirting with
the girl in the uh I remember that yeah
okay all right Fair all right so what's
next is it ever okay to
regift 1 million per yes you know why
because it's mine you can't give me
something and then lay claim to it
forever right I my only stipulation is I
think you can't regift in the same group
of people like oh yeah that's gnarly you
know if I get a gift from my
sister-in-law I'm not going to give it
to the other sister-in-law next
Christmas it has to go to a different a
whole different Christmas all right
let's unwind this real quick here's the
regifting rules you can't do that you
also can't give reift something that you
got from a previous lover to your
current lover oh gosh no no that's a
horrible thing to do don't do that I
know but it could I mean it could see
being no no no no no no cuz I never
would have thought of that you came up
with it real fast so that's why I'm just
thinking if I was like my wife's like
here you go and I'm like oh my gosh it's
amazing you're the same size as the guy
I dated before and he you know he loved
it so I thought would too then like o
don't do that um and then the third one
is I don't have a third one well you
have to like you know take the tag off
of it that says you know you don't
scratch out from Dan and make sure
there's no old wrapping paper still
stuck to it with the tap act like you
you did it but my biggest one is yeah
you just can't do it in the same group
of people CU like hey didn't I give you
that last year I do think yeah it be
funny like I didn't like it so I'm gonna
see if this guy likes it exactly I kind
of I appreciate that all right good call
way to go questions for humans change
your life talk to your
family all right let's go out to
Montgomery Alabama and talk to Help Me
Rhonda help help Mir Rhonda what's
up hey Dr John how are you good I'm
pretty much over caffeinated this
morning I'm a little bit uh I I can I
can tell a little bit I was snorting it
off my counter so what's up nice well um
I'm totally fangirling right now first
of all because I have so much respect
for you so
I thought I needed to talk to somebody
about this topic you are the first
person that came to my mind well that
makes me feel that makes me feel good
thank you you're welcome um so my
husband is in a job that um the job is
um very fulfilling for him but the
management is horrible and therefore it
makes him in a horrible mood um and it's
literally starting to affect our
marriage and I don't know what to do to
help oo okay can I blow up this whole
Paradigm sure all right um are you
comfortable saying what his job
is um he is a maintenance supervisor for
a large religious
organization oh he works for Jesus that
gets dicey all right okay so and you
should know he's a preacher kid this
might play into what your does 1,00% it
does yeah well that makes it even easier
so here's what we're going to
do there are I'm just going to say men
but I know there's men and women okay
but for this case I'm just going to use
the word men so everybody just take 30
40% off okay men go to war men clean
sewers men clean body parts off of
walls men um are
proctologists men men give
colonoscopies um right they do all sorts
of
things and I know women do all those
things too okay but in this case we're
talking about your husband the problem
is not doing the job it's not even the
management of his
job I don't want to blame the job or his
boss for how he chooses to treat his
family how he chooses to treat
himself now here's where that gets
really uncomfortable inside a home it's
actually I'm already uncomfortable I
know you know why because it's easier
for you you can sleep better at night
blaming his
boss but it's real tough to sleep when
you go oh wait a minute you're making
this
choice and so I think we have had this
Collective
whacko whacko um idea over the last
decade last 15 years simply because
we've had some wild economic um like uh
windfalls right just we've created
wealth over the last well we've borrowed
it actually but we've created wealth
over the last 10 15 years that never
existed in the in the world right and so
because of that we've started blaming
all of our uncomfortable moments on the
job how hard it is it's to the boss is
mean bosses have always been mean
what suddenly changed is people stopped
doing the things that they needed to do
to be well when they walked in that
front
door see what I'm saying oh yeah
so if you go the problem is
not how hard his job is the problem is
not how much of a jerk his boss is I'll
get to the jerk bosses in a minute okay
cuz that is a problem I don't want to
blow over that but I want to put the way
he treats his family and ultimately his
bad
mood that's his to
own and that's terrifying for you I do
not want that to be true but it is
true his boss is not walking in the
front door and slamming things and
screaming at you and cracking open a
beer and saying hey I don't even care
that's not his boss that's your husband
now in all fairness he does not do that
he's just super grumpy I'm just I'm just
I'm just making it up it'd probably be
better if he did a beer right you might
be less grumpy all the time maybe so my
question is what is grumpy protecting
him
from and the sad hard part about this
call is you can't answer that only he
can you're
correct well I don't know I wouldn't
know how to answer that right and it
probably goes back to he's seen how the
sausage is made at a at a religious
organization his whole life
and if you work back there for a long
time and you um don't do things to
protect your soul it can get real
gnarly uhuh right it can it can wear you
down here's whose fault that is not his
wife he does not get a pass on treating
his wife with disrespect or being grumpy
period period he doesn't and here's more
important he doesn't get to create a
home that his kids don't want to come
home
to Simply weers well so they're not
coming back are they no that's right no
that's
right one of my chief transitions as an
adult one of the things that I did a
control alt delete on was I want to
create a home full of warmth and
laughter and memories so that my kids
always want to come back MH and that
means and by the way I work in a a
really difficult job I play it off and
laugh a lot um but my job's hard and
it's got tons of travel and tons of
midnight meet and greets and 600 a.m.
meet and greets after like it's hard
it's a tough job plus hey write a book
in the hood that's tough and that means
it's my
job to make sure I'm seeing a counselor
to make sure I'm exercising I'm eating
right I sleep which means I can't eat
certain things cuz if I eat certain
things I don't sleep last night I was
exhausted and I went with my buddy
Michael and George camel and a couple
others we went to a comedy show I
actually wanted to go to bed but I knew
my body needed to hang out with my
friends and laugh really hard with some
great guys right I got to do those
things so I walk in my front
door and end up with a morning like I
had this morning I was very very tired
but me and my daughter played the
funniest spin around the you see what
I'm saying MH I do those things so that
I'm not grumpy it's not my boss's fault
it's not my job's fault it's mine so may
I ask a follow-up question you got
it um so this is my third marriage okay
we've been married eight years um I we
were both in long-term marriages like I
had a practice one that lasted a short
while and then we both had long
marriages and now we're married each
other for eight years okay and I can't
help but
feel that his mood is directed toward me
even though rationally I know is not so
what can I do for myself so I'm going to
ask you hard questions is that okay yeah
what kind of environment have you
created for him to come home
to loving I hope well let's put let's
put loving aside I want to talk about
feelings when he opens that door does
the house feel
hilarious and fun and oh my gosh I'm so
glad you're here or is it a loving house
he open opens the door and it's like hey
put don't put your shoes inside this
house do not bring that bag in here
gross get that
out
um so I'm not listen I'm not saying that
he needs he he should bring his shoes in
right I I see what you're saying um
probably a little bit of both I am super
happy to see him but then it's you know
I I got to get dinner done he needs to
come in the house way right yeah I need
him to I need him to behave so I don't
have to worry about that in addition to
everything else and nothing makes me
more grumpy than when my mom starts
lecturing me I knew you were gonna say
that I knew you were gonna say that they
quit being his
mom quit being his mom what does that
mean hey that doesn't mean that he just
Stomps mud through the house mhm what
that means is
is you take him out for breakfast and
you say hey we're 8 years in I want this
to be my ride or die you are my rider
die and he is I know when you bring mud
in the house like when that when the
house is unclean I feel
unsafe I feel like I'm failing you I
feel like I'm failing our marriage I
feel like I got one job and I'm not
doing it right it honors me when that's
different than I told you right or even
if you didn't say don't say the words I
told you he can feel that tone all over
your body language when you go pick up
his shoes and throw them out on the
front
porch and again I'm just making stuff up
right um yes it also
is if you tell him that and this is a
common thing that again I'm totally
generalizing here please people who
listen to this don't blow me up in the
comments I know it goes both ways I
know but
often a wife may go after her husband's
job which in a strange way goes after
his
identity and he has to either shut the
conversation down or defend
himself because he might might be even
more true with the preacher's kid that's
right he might see himself working a job
under a tyrant because he works unto
God and part of his calling since he was
zero years old is to have a miserable
life on behalf of something bigger than
himself so that everybody else can
worship
right wow uhhuh and
so there's a different thing if you sit
down and go your job is killing you yada
y that's different
then um I love you and I can't tell you
when I just think about your life how
proud I am of you that you've given up
every Sunday for your entire life to
serve other people so they can have an
an experience of meeting God and I don't
want you to Die
Young I don't want you to have a heart
attack I want you to walk in this house
and be so happy and joyful to walk in
here can we create that
world that's a very different he doesn't
that's an invitation it's not he doesn't
have to defend
himself and when you say you're just
being grumpy that's really vague
language I want you to be very very
specific when
you
yell it scares me to death when I get
the sense from your body that you don't
want me near you I always want you near
me that's F right there that's what I'm
talking about you see what I'm saying
the way my exactly the way my wife put
it was John you have a nuclear reactor
in your chest and I can all whole house
can feel it
[Music]
mhm and we all want to come closer to
you but your body's telling us to get
away and I had to go deal with that I
had to go sit with the counselor and say
some hard hard hard
stuff and like happened this morning I'm
starting to say a new sentence that I
haven't said ever and that was to my
daughter Josephine get off me I got to
go to
work because she can't stop being around
me now because that reactor's
disassembled I still get mad I still get
frustrated good grief I'm not a robot
but man that sense of peace and calm is
rad out of my body not that sense of get
away from
me but if he's going to a boss that
belittles him and he has parents that
he's still trying to live up
to and he's been a preachers kid his
whole life so every time he goes to the
bathroom he has to do it just right or
somebody's going to comment on
it and then he comes home to more
criticism man that's a tough
road is that fair
yeah
yeah it is um it kind of turned into a
self-fulfilling prophecy because exactly
fan of yours as well and when I told him
that you and I had an appointment to
talk his theer
changed so I think he saw that it was
serious enough to me that I needed help
yeah and because he loves me he's making
a greater
effort this last but let's don't make
him do an effort over and above your
criticism and your disdain and your
patting him on the head as my gross
little boy that just needs to do it
right I don't like to think that that's
what I do you might not you might not
but ask him do you feel like I belittle
you do you feel like when you come home
you have yet another boss that you can't
make happy because if so I'm so
sorry I'm trying to that's a good
question I'm trying here's the I've
talked about this more recently um
publicly for the first time here's the
question that changed my
marriage how do me and my wife want our
home to feel like when we walk in the
front
door for her here's a couple of things
that she asked me to do through tears we
live way out in the country she said
when you get home before me and it's
dark will you turn the porch lights on
so I can see it for we have like a mile
long driveway or a quarter mile long
driveway can you turn the porch lights
on it makes me feel like the home is
well our house is welcoming me home
will you clean up all these piles
everywhere because I walk home and
there's piles everywhere and I inhale
real sharply versus exhaling and
dropping my
shoulders now a clean house isn't a mom
scolding a little boy for me a clean
house is me telling my wife I love
you and for her I asked when I come home
I need 10 or 15 minutes before you start
asking questions about hey what do we do
and what about this and do you get this
paid and I just need a minute to come in
and my preference would be if we could
just hug right when I walk in the
door and dude she is
amazing and I love hearing my kids
running around yelling like see see what
I'm saying we created the house that we
wanted we want it to feel and then we
had to reverse engineer what does that
mean right and that might mean honey
when you get home I want the house to
feel I I want I want you to walk in that
door so
bad and if you're tents from your last
meeting when you walk in it's my it
scares my
body my body goes into protection not
into
invitation and he can say all right I'll
get off of work and I'll go to the gym
for 30 minutes and just walk on a
treadmill I'll go walk around the
park I'll exhale I'll pray I'll listen
to a podcast I'll do whatever I need to
do so that I walk in my shoulders are
dropped right that's a totally different
world we're talking
about and by the way I don't think
either of you are bad I don't I know
this this is not the job's fault real
quick before I I get off the call here
toxic E I hate the word toxic now it's
just so beat down Bad Bosses ruin people
destroy people makes it very hard to
stay above
water and so um I'm calling on bosses
all over the country to stop sucking
stop start loving the people that you
work with and by the way if you love the
people who work for you and who are
trying to help people out of the
marketplace and you love them back in
instead of saying ah told but instead of
you say hey man how can I serve you and
get this done we have a deadlines you
got to show up and work you got to go
Full Tilt how can I support you and how
can I love you in this
position you will serve more customers
and you'll make more customers happy you
will help them in their day-to-day lives
which is what business should be about
and you'll make more
money but badly laders man if you use
your arrogance and your strength and
your position of power to beat up on
people shame on you
dude you're going to collapse your
business because you create a business
of people who don't want to make
mistakes not a business of people who
want to love customers
well Bad Bosses
choose as for me in my house we're going
to choose to love people and take care
of them and demand excellence and we're
going to go help people make that how
you practice too thanks for the call
Ronda you're awesome we be right
back hey it's delone and the holidays
are coming up and holidays can be
stressful have you ever found yourself
hiding in a closet from all the chaos
and the noise and the political opinions
or been sitting in your car with your
hands gripping the steering wheel just
looking up to the sky saying why God why
I know you have and I have too so I'm a
Christian guy and listen regardless of
where you find yourself in the Christian
faith tradition you you can find peace
with hallow the number one Christian
Prayer app on planet Earth hallow has
Christmas prayers and meditations this
holiday season Bible stories and
peaceful holiday music to help you
de-stress While You Work Shop drive or
hang out with family which are times you
probably need peace the most I even
listen to some of the music while I work
out their prey 25 challenge offers daily
devotions based on the writings of CS
Lewis and these writings are voiced by
Liam niss or you can listen to scripture
read by Jonathan roomy from The Chosen
and you can get hallow free for three
months at hall.com
dealone find peace for free for three
dealone all right we are back I am super
excited to bring you this
conversation um over the last few years
the great Don Madson she goes by the
minimal mom she's got a an enormous
YouTube show that's just jam-packed with
helpful stuff and you might be asking
yourself why does a guy who pretends
he's a tough guy with a bunch of tattoos
who goes hunting and loves mixed martial
arts why does he hang out and have a
friendship with the minimal
mom a woman who helps women clean their
homes and moms clean their homes and I
guess down dads clean their homes I I'll
tell you why cuz Dawn is a great human
being very very wise not only at this
idea of decluttering and creating space
and freedom in your home but as you'll
see in this conversation um she's
somebody that I call personally because
when I was writing building an unanxious
life I got stuck I was surrounded by so
much stuff and it was one of the first
times in a long time I didn't know what
to do I didn't know who to call I didn't
know where to go so I called my friend
Dawn and this conversation we talk about
mental health and clutter and stuff and
identity she's so wise full of so much
wisdom and she's just a great person
like I said so check out this
conversation between me and my great
friend Don Matson the minimal Mom right
here conversations I had with college
students over two decades
and landing on this word Addiction and
so when I think of addiction they've
told us for years it was a moral issue
right if you're addicted to something
it's because you're terrible you're bad
and then it shifted to well it's
actually we got a picture of somebody's
brain and so we found it's an addiction
it's a disease right right and now the
conversation has shifted to no no no
addiction is your body trying to solve
for the madness that it's in right
whether that's old trauma stuff or
whether it is a uh something hard or
tragic or abusive that you're sitting in
the middle of addiction works yeah right
until it doesn't until it kills you yeah
right right and so you and I have talked
offline and I haven't talked about this
very much publicly
but I can be
so good about my diet and so good about
exercise and so good about plugging in
with my kids and so good about like
working hard to be a good
husband there is something protective
about the chaos that is all the clutter
in my life and I think I called you
during writing the book I stumbled on
some literature about anxiety and
clutter being surrounded by stuff yeah
and a brain that's designed for scarcity
has found itself in the 21st century
surrounded by just stuff right all the
time right
and I don't know what to do and you know
I've talk like I've sit there in my
house surrounded by the stuff and
getting rid of it feels like I'm losing
a part of me right and the definition of
addiction is repeated Behavior despite
increasing mounting negative
consequences right and yeah I can't stop
you know what I mean and so I don't
understand this connection between
clutter and addiction and we we've we've
tossed it off as mental health dis I
don't think that's it I think it's
something deeper than that that I'm
wrapped up in these things yeah help me
please right right well and we like to
call it identity clutter and so you're
absolutely not alone I think this is
something many can resonate with um for
some it's books and guitars teachers
especially they find a lot of identity
in books they're also in the academic
world um craft supplies uh workout gear
hobby
things we're constantly trying to show
the world look this is who I am right
and you've said this before your books
look how smart I am my books say that
right and so what if you take all my
books away and my guitars and my craft
supplies then what's the world going to
think of me and that's not wrong though
right like you talk about this in a
tribe we need to look successful so we
don't get left behind so that's why I
want brand name clothes and a nice
vehicle it it's not wrong that we want
to look successful or we want to look
cool we want to fit in so my body's
doing right by itself it's not wrong
right the problem is for most of us so I
like to talk about this as inventory so
everything in our house is inventory
that we have to manage and for women I
think we have to manage more than men
honestly um and so everything is
inventory and so many of these things
are useful they're helpful they're make
our life easier but it's all inventory
that we have to manage
and so we can have a certain amount of
books and guitars and that's great
they're useful they're helpful you can
go down to your basement hang out and
jam until it gets to the point where
it's not and so it's kind of like this
like you know scale tips right and
you're like no I don't go down there and
feel inspired and I just want to hang
out I feel stressed because there's way
too much inventory down there and that's
where our friend fumio saki comes in cuz
he's like he he calls it the silent
to-do list and those things nagging at
you all the time what does that stuff
say to you but that's very similar to a
drink it's fun to have a drink with your
buddies yeah and then the second one
yeah and then it's when you can't stop
it's fun to order books on Amazon it is
and they show up I got another one
yesterday and like so I'm off book tour
I I like to go down a rabbit hole with
one author and that's cool except I
usually get two books in and then I quit
and I've got seven other ones and I'm
always going to get to him right yeah
another older book of this one author
that I love showed up and it was sitting
on the thing and my wife puts it out now
as this like Shining Moment Like This
this uh Beacon of Shame just you did
this right Y and I I can't tell you the
feeling I got it felt so good like I got
it you know what I mean yeah cuz it was
going to make you smarter I don't have
open it cuz I got I I already have the
reward totally right right that's that's
an unhealthy addiction that's not right
that's not a whole it's not good it it
would be okay if you went down to your
basement and got rid of four more books
that's it that's it right yeah but I
need those to tell okay too and that's
just it and and I think this idea with
the silent to-do list it's this idea
that all of our stuff is sending us
messages read me play me take care of me
organize me don't let me get wrecked and
fumia will even say the longer we've
neglected something the louder the
messages get right what a loser you are
because you have not read me you have
not taken care of me and it really
represents these broken commitments with
oursel right lies to yourself totally
that's addiction I said when I bought
that book I was going to read it or at
least skim it right and I have not even
done that and so it all represents these
broken commitments to oursel and what
does that do makes us feel even worse
about ourselves yeah you keep secrets in
the moment that's right
right but what do we do right we're
still here with all the books yeah I I I
think it's I just my tenden is to skip
over this part which is the discomfort
with yeah the only path I can see
forward for me is submitting to like I'm
poweress here right it's it's that very
old it's that old 12-step thing like I I
Outsource my identity to books CU they
make me feel like I'm smart I Outsource
my identity to guitars cuz they are some
magical link to when I was 18 and I
played in Punk clubs right and I can't
let that guy go yeah I Outsource myself
to the fanciest hunting gear because
I've convinced myself that if it all
goes down I'm all right I'm that right
it's and I can just keep going yeah but
I have to deal with the fact that I
continue I can be proud of myself for
not Outsourcing how I feel to the
internet right I don't people can leave
me in comments that's fine yeah I don't
Outsource myself to my mom and dad or my
in-laws right they don't get a vote
right sure but dude right there's
something so powerful about these things
and I have to sit in that discomfort and
say I do do that right I do let books I
do let guitars and to people listening
your dishes your perfect sets your
furniture your perfectly made bed all
the like the throw pillows right right
how much we Outsource stuff and then
that imaginary conversation that's what
when you told me that privately that
melted me like the are you just going to
give up on us remember remember when you
were cool yeah not going to read us
you're just going to be stupid forever
right oh you're not going to do the
dishes you're just going to be that kind
of husband that's just how you're going
to be and it never that voes those
voices never stop and I think that's why
then when you look at the research and
it literally says now clutter releases
stress hormones right like you have told
me in the past if your house is very
cluttered you don't feel safe in it your
body cannot fully relax and I think it
is it's because these messages we look
at it like it's just stuff it's a book
like it it doesn't talk it doesn't
breathe it does nothing right but but
that's why it's these messages so you
know I know the minimalists they have
their rule like the spontaneous
combustion rule right and I they even
asked you this at one point John if all
of your books spontaneously combusted
how would you feel and you had said I
would kind of feel relieved right
decisions made for me that's it yeah
there would be this Terror but also this
yeah but once the dust settled kind of
like oh good I don't have to make that
decision right right yeah and so that's
good though right because you you can
recognize then don't need all of these
books basically what you're saying is I
would be okay if some of these books go
you don't have to get rid of all of them
but unfortunately they didn't
spontaneously combust and you're still
there with them right so do I do right
and you've been trying to do this on
your own oh gosh yeah for a long time we
we do right we're like I got myself into
this mess I need to get myself out and
often we're embarrassed by the Clutter
yours is yours is kind of like
sophisticated clutter right books and
guitars like you know but for a lot of
us if I have a full bedroom stacked with
with boxes of stuff a basement an attic
I can't even imagine inviting someone
into that with me and I feel like you
would be the first to tell other people
call a friend you're going to give them
purpose right they're going to feel so
special when you pick up the phone and
call them and invite them over to help
you and so what keeps you from inviting
someone into this with you shame I'm
going to use your own words against you
that it's not I realized it wasn't a
character flaw I just don't have the
skills that's it that's I'm not broken
I'm I'm not an idiot I'm not a loser I
don't know how to do it right so you've
probably heard of body doubling right
have you heard of body doubling it's a
it's a great tactic for people with ADHD
all it is is having tell me more right
all it is is having someone come and
help you so I have an appointment
Saturday morning I'm going to have
someone who I trust with this uh they're
going to come over and often what's very
helpful is that you might need to tell
the stories of some of these things you
might need to say oh I remember in grad
school when I got this book or this
person came came to speak and I was so
enthralled with them and I wanted to be
like them or I love this thing they said
that's always stuck with me so I feel
like I need to keep the book so I don't
forget that or I don't lose it or you
know my goal for today is to clear off
this one shelf and so you're literally
just here to hold me accountable is that
okay to go like do one shelf today oh
yeah yes we often glamorize like I need
to set aside the whole weekend and I
need to get this all done and that is
too overwhelming for most of us because
this is it's a lot of work I mean you're
literally going book by book and saying
do I need this do I not and you'll say
because we're trying to imagine the
future right am I going to need this
book in the in the future am I going to
want to reference it again am I gonna I
mean you're awesome at quoting other
people in your books right and so I love
it like how you bring in just everything
and so you might what if I need it in
the future but that's anxiety right
trying to predict what I am going to
need in the future so there's also a
part where we need to accept that there
is risk involved with this MH there is
some risk and that's a great if if you
can invite someone over to help you body
double again body doubling is just
literally having someone come over they
can do it virtually I mean it's
scientifically proven this works
virtually this is why like clean with me
videos are very popular um because
you're literally cleaning alongside
someone else even though it's virtually
I even heard of that it's like doing
aerobics online it's awesome it's not
surprising though right because we're
made for community and we need people
right so um so not surprising so that's
body doubling and you might need to tell
the person okay here's my goal here's my
fear um and you need to tell me it's
okay we don't want to invite someone
over who's like very creative and like
oh you might want to keep that for some
no you're fired like you don't you don't
work for this and so you might need to
tell them like hey I like there is some
risk we don't know for sure if I'm going
to need this in the future so just
remind you if I hold something up and
I'm kind of going back and forth if I'm
going back and forth it's a sign I don't
need it right if it's not a clear yes
it's a no and so that sounds like a good
like Instagram Max him but that's that's
real it is real because we only use 20%
of the stuff in our house as Americans
we only use 20% of the stuff in our
house but we have to acknowledge and
this is where I think sometimes people
oversimplify it is that there is risk
involved with this so I grew up on a
farm in Minnesota my dad was phenomenal
so when you're on a farm there are
things going wrong every single day
correct all the time and my dad it was
so fun because he would see each thing
that went wrong is a problem that needed
to be solved he didn't get frustrated he
was like hm how are we going to do this
and if his initial fix what he tried to
do didn't work he was like oh I guess we
got to try something else right and so I
grew up in this environment where it was
okay to make mistakes it was okay to try
and not all of us grew up in that type
of environment and so eight years ago
when I I have four kids ages four and
under my house is a disaster and I'm
like this sucks like I am not enjoying
being a mom this is not the picture that
I thought this was going to look like
nothing like it and so looking around
and then I hear this podcast with Joshua
Becker who's a well-known minimalist and
he's like did you know you don't have to
have all this stuff and I'm like no I
didn't I thought this is what you have
when you have four kids in a house and
and everything and because I'm okay with
taking risks and it's okay if I make a
mistake I could over the course of the
next year get rid of 85% of our stuff
and I could do an experiment and I could
just see what was going to happen and it
turns out that it was one of the best
decisions that I ever made I do not miss
any of this stuff and so sometimes we
need to borrow that confidence from
others those who have gone before us I
me you look at the minimalists my
goodness they're preaching it from the
rooftops right guys this this stuff
doesn't fix anything we look at you know
we're collecting data right like could
talk I need data you have not read any
of those books in how many years right
and so sometimes we need facts and we
need to remind ourselves like okay this
feels unsettling because maybe for some
of us we're in an environment even now
where it's not okay to make mistakes and
there are some someone in my household
and I don't think you're in that
situation but for others that is going
to they are just ready to point it out
if you got rid of something and now you
need it again it's very unlikely you
need it again but in the off chance they
are ready to say see this decluttering
doesn't work see you're just going to go
buy all this stuff again or you
shouldn't have bought in the first place
and exact you're right right it's very
complicated I so as you're talking I
keep landing on this one thing and I I
I'm always stunned and it sounds like
what you're telling me is
is I have to come to terms with the fact
that I'm not
19 and what I have to do is grieve that
Gap right like I'm not I'm not 19 and
there's not a chance that some band's
going to call me that's that ship has
sailed that doesn't mean I can't play
guitar and that doesn't mean that I
can't jam with my son and my daughter
and have fun yeah but I have to let that
part go and that's hard but again I
think that's where inviting someone else
in it we need to tell our story right we
need a big part of grieving is someone
else witnessing it it's right that's it
you have to you have to say it out loud
and so to invite someone over and to say
hey I got this guitar when I was this
old and when I had this dream and so
this is hard for me to like oh like let
them know that here's the other problem
it's I've only recently started like not
just like trying to make enough money to
have groceries and so these things
aren't old relics this is me trying to
recapture this is new money right this
is stuff like I'm using money to buy
18-year-old dreams the guitar that the
kid never could afford when I was
playing or the shoes I couldn't have and
I have to let go if I have like one
superpower when it comes to like writing
and stuff am I it's a freakish ability
to remember there's one line in this one
book that I read nine years ago and I'll
find it and I have to let that
superpower go cuz there's like there's
this one recipe that one time there's
this one one dish that everyone laughs
at when they come over and I think we
all hold on to those that
thing and suddenly that it's not a
superpower it feels like it is but it's
not you know what I mean it's not it's
pretend yeah and so that's again where
we can have someone to witness it we go
a little bit at a time so again we're
not going to try and declutter all your
books in in one weekend because what
happens if you will do even if you say
I'm going to do 10 books today is you
start to gain confidence in yourself and
you start to say hey I got rid of those
10 books and I didn't actually miss them
the world didn't end you no and then I
got rid of 10 more and now there's a
hundred gone and it actually feels
better down here right I feel like I can
woo I can start to relax a little bit I
don't walk in this room and think oh I
need to do this and I need to organize
these and I need to dust these and I
should really should read that one right
and then we realize like you know the
silent to-do list is quieting down I can
start to enjoy this space how I'd hoped
but that's where I think doing it
gradually we gain that confidence in
ourselves so that we do trust the
decisions that we're making uh one other
thing don't start with identity clutter
sentimental stuff the hardest stuff
start in your kitchen see I think the
rest of your house is probably pretty
simplified uh don't start I mean on the
Spectrum like this is the hardest stuff
like you are working through the hardest
stuff right now so it can be helpful to
start in other areas of your home your
kitchen your clothes stuff that's more
easily replaced well clothes might be
she said this morning there's a stack of
t-shirts and she said hey we've exceeded
the number of hangers she said it's time
to uh um and she goes or you can go by
more hangers and that's like always like
you can go buy more hangers or you can
and dude I'm hoping you'll make the
right decision shirts it's like I love
that one I can wear that and it's insane
it's it's not rational right right man
all right so I'm going to take from this
two things and tell me if I'm crazy the
Clutter the stuff
is almost like it it is it's the gas
light on the I mean it's the the engine
light on the car it's not the problem
it's this sense that I'm using other
stuff to try to feel good about myself
that's number one and number
two you weaponized to my own words
against like I can't do this I got to I
got to say I can't do this by myself and
I need to get somebody else to help me
yeah who will be honest with me which
for me is probably going to be my wife
and if I I I can't think of a greater
aphrodesiac in my home if I was to be
like hey would you sit with me for like
4 hours help me get some of this stuff
out I can't even tell you what that
would be in our house you know I mean um
uh gosh I just have to I just have to do
it but again small piece that's right
you know 10 books I start but tell me if
this fails it feels like it fails and I
feel like I try it but I feel like it's
also like a like a little blankie that
keeps me warm is I'll put stuff in a box
and then I put it in the attic and say
I'm going to I'm going to practice I
think it's got to go yeah I think you
need to just fully get it out of your
house you need to complete it get it out
that's the only way you're actually
going to build trust with yourself
that's yeah cuz I know it's out yeah no
safety nets with you're right on that
yeah yeah okay well thanks for coming by
and
helping hey delone here look people
always say the holidays are the most
wonderful time of the year and for some
of us the holidays are great but they're
Mayhem for all all of us you're probably
traveling all over the place talking to
family members you didn't ask for by the
way shopping GH trying to make it to all
the parties and no one will turn off the
Christmas music but inside the chaos
remember you still have a choice the
choice to take care of yourself taking
care of yourself begins with a good
night's sleep and I believe good sleep
starts with an amazing mattress that's
why my family sleeps on dreamcloud
dreamcloud mattresses have a combination
of gel memory foam and coil technology
that keeps you comfortable all night and
right now dreamcloud is running their
biggest offer ever exclusively for our
listeners 40% off all mattresses plus an
additional $50 in savings by using promo
code John deloney visit dreamcloud
sleep.com and enter promo code John
deloney to get your new mattress and the
rest your body
needs that's dreamcloud sleep.com with
code John
deloney all right we're back let's go
out to Little Rock Aransas and talk to
Tracy what's up
Tracy hi Dr John um thank you for taking
my call today of course thanks for
calling thank you yes sir and I I love
your show and I just got your new book
building a non-anxious life I haven't
read it yet but I have it very cool um
okay here's my here's my problem I live
alone in my home is chronically
cluttered um to the point that I really
won't let anybody in my home um and this
bothers me really bad uh about myself
about my home and I'm just afraid that
it's a symbol of maybe a bigger issue
that I'm not seeing or else I'm just a
floss I don't
know oh I don't think so um when you say
it's surrounded by
clutter is that
a is that a truthful state or is that a
very nice way of saying you're afraid
you're a hoarder and you've got trash
and garbage and scary stuff everywhere
okay I'm not a hoarder that yeah there's
not trash like that it's more like every
um so it's not a hoarder situation
there's not too much stuff it's just
there's a lot of paper sitting now a lot
of mail that hadn't be dealt dealt with
or filing okay uh maybe dishes on the
counters in the sink um multiple items
on the coffee table in the bathroom
counter just stuff that I use and I
think oh I put it up I'm just going to
use it again or I don't want to file um
who wants to file on your day off um you
know things like that but I have a
friend that when he comes over he says
your house is too cute for it to be this
messy okay and so that so it sounds more
messy than gross yes yes okay do you
collect
things no no
okay so at my I've got collections of
books and collections of music equipment
and guitars and collections of hunting
stuff so I've got things that I've
wrapped my identity around but it's just
tons of stuff and a lot of it's really
nice stuff but it's just everywhere
you're talking about you have piles and
junk and stuff and I just don't want to
put it
away yeah it's okay it seems like
another job if I'm off work uh to have
to go to and I keep thinking well I'll
just knock it
out I'll knock it out I can get it clean
I'll have somebody come over and kind of
monitor me and make me stay task
oriented and I can keep it cleaned up
for a while and then it'll pile up again
okay um what is what does the Clutter
get
you what does it get me it makes me feel
anxious and stressed out and I yeah
there's something else on the other side
what does it get you you mentioned it
gets you some time off from what you
feel is like work
yes what does it get you just dropping
the stuff where it is not putting the
dishes back not cleaning up your stuff
off the kitchen off the bathroom counter
what does that get you oh nothing it
digs me deeper in a hole no I'll get you
something or your body wouldn't keep
doing it okay um maybe like an
unsupervised
child how long have people been telling
you what to
do and what to think and what to feel um
gosh I feel so independent uh it's just
this this is like my Achilles heel and
uh but you're not independent you're not
free no I'm not I'm I'm My Own hostage
in this house oh that's a good
word how long have you been a hostage in
your own home well I've been in this
home 15 years and I asked a friend of
mine recently how long has it been like
this because I thought before it was
because of the job I previously had
where I was a traveling sales rep and I
had a lot of work related brochure
sitting out but now I work from home now
and I thought well maybe it'll all get
cleaned up because I'm home um I have
had a health issue that's limited my
energy level and uh but that's I don't
think that's I can't even use that as an
excuse I just well and you see how that
becomes kind of recursive right you
don't feel super great so you don't pick
up after yourself and you open your eyes
and you feel stressed and immediately
like and then that's overcome with shame
and then you have less energy and you do
L you see how it works one way but it
also works the other way but how it
works that one way tell me about your
home growing up what' your home look
like um it was perfectly picked up uh
there was nothing sitting out you
couldn't leave anything sitting out at
all but if you opened a drawer or a
closet you could see everything crammed
in
there and I will say it was a um
alcoholic home so there was some chaos
emotional chaos going on there you go
but everything was pick up and the yard
looked great but it was all a facade yes
sir just like your smile was as a little
girl going to school yeah yes sir just
like you're probably a damn good
salesman saleswoman I did I did okay
yeah you did and nobody
knew right what do you do now I'm inside
sales what does that mean uh well I work
out of my home now but I'm still got a
sales position so I pretty much work
over the phone or the computer instead
of traveling pretty good at it yes oh
I'm okay I'm all right I ended up with u
a couple of health issues that kept me
from I don't have the energy level to
travel like I did
okay and I used to kind of think maybe
it was I'm older and maybe the health
you know
Health trouble so to speak um although
it's not completely debilitating um
about maybe that's it but I've had a
chronic history of this of course you
you said something really important at
the beginning of this call that I want
to Circle back to and I want you to
never forget this as long as you live
okay
okay you said I feel like if I clean up
on my day off I'm just doing work again
yes what that means in Reverse if I take
that as like a coin and I flip it to the
other side what you just told me is
my boss gets my first
fruit yes my boss and my job and my
customers are more important than me oh
wow it's my job to make sure everybody
else is taken care of and I'm not even
worth picking up the
garbage that's it and you know what you
grew up in the home of an alcoholic
you've been doing this your whole
freaking life yes sir you got it that's
it wow listen you have to flip that
around and say I can only serve my boss
and my customers and my family and my
kids and my friend if and only if I'm
whole and
okay and so the investment proposition
isn't that everybody gets stuff in their
account and you'll just spend whatever's
left the investment proposition is I
have to make sure my account is full so
that I can go take care of everybody
else okay are you a Christian yes sir
there's a reason Jesus pulled away and
went sat in the desert and prayed so
that he was anchored in and he could
repel off the edge and go be what
everybody else
needed and you're doing it the opposite
you're
right wow I knew I couldn't see it but
you you've put it into perspective for
me here's the hard part it's hard to un
to reverse this and the cool part is
it's super doable okay all right I'm
gonna I'm gonna give you I'm GNA walk
through a couple of things that I think
will help
immensely is that cool I'm right yes sir
I'm ready I want you to are you creative
crafty not really but do you have a
friend who is I could yes y all right I
want you to get a friend and I want you
to pay him 25 bucks or 50 bucks or
something to make you a sign get one of
your buddies who's like one of those
woodworker nerds who knows how to
woodwork everything and they're great at
it get one of those friends okay and I
want them to make you a sign that says
Don't Forget to
Remember okay and I want you to hang
that sign up in your living room right
when you walk in the door okay I also
want you to get that and write it on a
piece of paper or something or have a
small sign that you hang from your
rearview mirror or put it in your car
okay this was step one for me changing
my life okay here's why in the
moment when I'm starting to walk in with
a handful of like a a ER from uh some
food I just ate and a whole bunch of
books and the mail and my backpack full
of
junk I drop it down and then I go to the
sink and I grab something to eat and I
just drop the dish in
there and I literally don't see it right
then yes okay I'm just going from thing
to thing to thing and I'm tired I just
want to sit down it's when I get back up
from sitting down or get back up from
watching that show or get back even if
I'm trying to do something good I get
back in the house from that that workout
and I see all the piles of stuff and my
first thought is you're disgusting what
a
loser yeah I did same team uhhuh okay
the phrase don't forget to remember has
been transformative for me here's why I
see it in my car I don't have it there
anymore but I used to have it in my car
and I used to put it up in my house and
as I was getting out of my car I would
see it right as I'm getting out and it
would say don't forget to remember here
was what I was reminding myself don't
forget to remember how good it feels to
get into a clean car okay and then I
would stop and I would look and there's
two cups in my coffee and a wrapper of
some piece of candy I grabbed on the way
out and a book and and I just grabbed
all that
stuff and over time it became
automated okay just don't forget to
remember how good it feels to walk in
the door okay that's number one number
two I want you to create a new identity
for your home
okay here's what I mean by that very
similar to the call the first call in
today's show I want you to be very
specific and preferably talk to a friend
what do you want your home to feel like
when you walk in every morning when you
open your eyes what do you want to feel
like not what do you want to look like
feel like Airy light calm joyful fun
whatever it
is but I want you to start
there with an identity for your home
this is my safe warm fun laughter filled
place okay and so what has to be true so
that this can be warm and laughter
filled I got to throw that crap
away yeah but if you start with all
right every day I'm G to throw all the
trash away that will last for about four
days yes in my house my wife told me
years ago when there's piles when
there's stuff everywhere
I can't Brea like the way she described
it is she inhales real sharply instead
of
exhaling yes and so I know that when I
pick up my stuff I'm telling my wife I
love
you see how much different that is one
is an identity one is a bunch of
chores and so if your home is a warm
joyful workspace slash Retreat Center
then crap doesn't come in the door right
I'm not bringing McDonald's rappers into
this warm safe lovely space this is my
retreat
center the same as you know like you
don't put um motor oil on your
toothbrush I'm not putting that in my
mouth okay I'm not bringing this in my
house that's not who this house is
that's not who we are here and that
means I might sort mail in the front
yard and just throw it all
away I'm never gonna get on a arp's
elite program I'm never goingon to do
that so I'm not even bringing it in the
house yes I'm never going to buy another
couch on a credit card like I'm not H so
that doesn't come in the house it just
goes right in the
trash see what I'm saying got it yes sir
I do all right number two I wish this
wasn't the case this is what I had to do
you got to get a friend okay and um as
my friend Don Madson the minimal mom
goes by and I would I would strongly
recommend checking her stuff out minimal
mom you need to be minimalist at all but
she does a great step by step most of us
when we try to declutter we go after
everything all at the same time you just
said I just want to knock it
out yes your body over not it gets
overwhelmed and it shuts it down yes
exactly and then when it starts to shut
down Netflix is like I got
you and you just sit down there and turn
on right exactly oh my gosh how do you
know me because I'm you right so here's
what we do we get a friend and we pick
one room and we might only pick one wall
of one room okay I'm just going to clean
this wall off I'm going get all stuff
off these shelves I'm going to get all
these books out of here I'm going to get
rid of all this stuff because my
identity is warmth and laughter and joy
not look how smart I am because I read
these
books and yours might be Fillin the
blank right whatever it is okay okay but
get a friend and say hey we're going to
do one room and then I'm buying
coffee okay cool we're going to do one
half of one room then we're getting
coffee and they're going to want to push
you I'm here let's just go to the Next
Room nope it's what we got okay okay
we'll make it a process we'll have some
fun with it here is the um third
thing this is from fumio uh is it fumio
Sasaki I think it is a Japanese
minimalist um it's amazing what he said
he said all of our inanimate objects in
our home are having a conversation with
us 247
365 and so when you walk in the the door
and you see the pile of
mail it's quietly Whispering hey Tracy
are you going to open us you just going
to leave us here in this pile think of
all the good deals we got you're going
to pay full price for that I bet we have
a coupon in here what if your old old
boyfriend from high school finally wrote
you back and said he loved you right all
all that and we don't realize that the
dishes are like Are you seriously not
going to clean us up you slob you
freaking lazy slob are you serious yes
right and so what I want you to start
doing is talking back
okay I am going to put you away dishes
haha or I'm watching a show I'm not lazy
I work my butt off today and I'm
struggling with some health issues I'm
going to watch this show and then at
6:32 I'm getting up and I'm cleaning you
up I'm putting you
away I can do that
okay last sounds better than what I've
been saying to myself well here's what
you've been doing you've been talking to
Tracy not to the stuff
right and you got stuff in your closet
that one day you're going to lose the
weight or one day it'll come back in
fashion it's not Tracy it's not just is
not time for it to
go and you're gonna have a friend that's
gonna go through your closet with you
you're gonna buy them coffee it'll be
hilarious and sad you might cry it's
gonna be all of that okay okay here's
the last thing all right
stop stop talking to yourself like
that
yeah that is the last area where I've
really haven't handled the negative
selft talk I didn't even realize I was
doing it until we had this conversation
it never stops you are so mean to my
friend
Tracy and if you walked outside in your
front yard and heard a neighborhood guy
talking to his daughter like that you
would oh I'd come onlu I know you
would so treat
Tracy it's the reverse Golden Rule do
unto others as you would have them do
unto you
okay you take care of others you don't
take care of you on the
inside so at least treat yourself as
good as you would treat a
stranger okay fair I can do that yes sir
oh my goodness okay and I can follow the
six daily choices and my my promise is
if you'll go through those six daily
choices and begin to address
those you're going to have less and less
um room for trash in your house for
garbage just nonsense because your your
whole system will lighten
up that's what I've been trying to go
minim minimalist for a long time because
of that no that's like that's like
somebody just got out of knee surgery
getting rid of your crutches don't do
that okay you're right you might get
there eventually but people who just go
scorched Earth and get rid of everything
in their house and that stuff has become
an important part of of their body
trying to keep them safe and well okay
dude you just go to the next advice okay
that's why you go slow and that's why
you go with somebody and you process it
and you feel it okay do that you'll
you'll see your buddy's face you'll see
your buddy's face and they'll be like oh
my gosh what is all this crap and you'll
feel embarrassed I want you to put your
hand on your chest feel the
embarrassment feel it okay and go yeah
I'm I'm getting
better yeah I wasn't okay but I'm on the
way after you get this whole thing
cleaned up I want you to take before and
afters okay will you send them to me
yeah does I'd be so
happy it's going to have to be in
sections piece by piece by piece by
piece by piece we're going to do in
sections it's going to be amazing Tracy
I'm super super proud of you and by the
way this will be two steps forward four
steps
back five steps forward three steps
back we're going to slowly make our way
to this okay this is a lifetime of you
putting everybody in front of you you're
going to have to practice over a period
of time finally loving Tracy enough to
say no I'm it's not I'm not working on
my day off this is my first day of the
week and I work for me first so I take
care of me first and I make sure my home
is the safe wonderful warm Retreat I
want it to be then my boss gets what's
next we're going to flip this whole
thing
around so proud of you ah you're awesome
Tracy we'll be right
back hey what's up deloney here listen
you and me and everybody body else on
the planet has felt anxious or burned
out or chronically stressed at some
point in my new book building a non
anxious life you'll learn the six daily
choices that you can make to get rid of
your anxious feelings and be able to
better respond to whatever life throws
at you so you can build a more peaceful
nonanxious life get your copy today at
john.com
all right we wrap up today's show Nate
dog behind the screens
picked this band and I said who is this
band and he said they make pretty
music we need more pretty music in the
world especially from a guy that mostly
listens to Pennywise
and I Prevail so good for you not true
no that's me oh you okay the Cinematic
Orchestra song's called to build a home
goes like this there's a house built out
of stone wooden floors walls and window
sills tables and chairs sounds like he's
just going through all the parts of a
home that's kind of cool it's like
architectural digest wooden floors walls
and window sills tables and chairs worn
by all the dust there's a place where I
don't feel alone there's a place where I
feel at home I built a home for you for
me until it disappeared from me from you
and now it's time to leave and turn to
dust and way to bring down a room
Nate I built you a home and we all
died pretty music is that
it why the cracks of the skin I climbed
to the top I climbed to the tree to see
the world when the gusts came around to
blow me down I held on tightly as you
held on me held on as tightly as you
held on
me actually I'm going to go listen the
song right now it sounds beautiful it's
kind of
[Music]
sad cool man hey I love you guys stay in
school be nice to each other unlike
Kelly love y'all